AGREEMENT AND DESPITE U.S.
SANCTIONS.
>> Bret: RICH EDSON, LIVE AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE HOPES IT
WILL BE NO MEDDLING OR TAMPERING
DURING NEXT WEEK'S ELECTION AND
HE SAYS HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
SPENT A LOT OF TIME AND MONEY TO
TRY TO PREVENT THAT.
TONIGHT WE GO INSIDE THE
GOVERNMENT'S PLANS TO KEEP THE
ELECTION SECURE.
HERE IS CATHERINE HERRIDGE WITH
A FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVE.
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN ACTIVITY THAT
WE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO A FOREIGN
NATION.
>> KIRSTJEN NIELSEN WILL SEE O
>> KIRSTJEN NIELSEN WILL SEE E
>> KIRSTJEN NIELSEN WILL SEE S
THE SITUATION ROOM ON ELECTION
NIGHT.
AS FAR AS ONLINE EFFORTS USING
PROPAGANDA AND INFORMATION TO
PROMOTE DECEPTION AND
DECISION-MAKING.
>> MANSON SPOKE EXCLUSIVELY
ABOUT THE NEW SECURITY MEASURES,
ONE DAY AFTER SHE AND FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY IN THE
NATION INTELLIGENCE CHIEF BREAKS
THE PRESIDENT.
>> BASIC MESSAGE WAS ELECTIONS
ARE THE HEART OF OUR DEMOCRACY
AND IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT THAT AMERICANS HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THEM.
>> THE NICE NATIONAL
CYBERSECURITY CENTER HAS
MONITORED CONVERSATIONS OF ABOUT
90% OF REGISTERED VOTERS.
MORE THAN HALF OF ALL STATES
HAVE COMPLETED VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENTS.
>> IF THERE WAS AN ATTACK ON THE
VOTING TUESDAY THERE WOULD BE A
U.S. GOVERNMENT RESPONSE AT THE
PRESIDENT'S POSITION.
THERE WOULD BE A CYBER RESPONSE.
IS THAT ON THE TABLE?
>> EVERYTHING IS ON THE TABLE.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
SAID THEY AMPLIFY ISSUES THAT
DEFY VOTERS.
LAST CYCLE, A RUSSIAN TROLL
FACTORY RALLIED ONLINE FOR
SPONSORED BOATERS.
VOTERS.
>> WE SEE AGGRESSIVE ACTIONS BY
MULTIPLE COUNTRIES TO INFLUENCE
THE WAY IN WHICH AMERICANS THINK
AND IN SOME CASES SUCH AS CHINA
TO PERHAPS CHANGE OUR POLICIES.
>> NIELSEN NOTES THAT GOVERNMENT
AND HACKERS MAY NOT BREACH
VOTING SYSTEMS BUT THEY STILL
EXPLOIT ELECTION NIGHT.
>> SO CONFUSION, DISCORD AND
MISTRUST BY PLACING STORIES AND
STATE-SPONSORED MEDIA THAT
SOMETHING WAS WRONG.
>> ELECTION DAY HOMELAND
SECURITY SAYS THEY WILL ALSO
PARTNER WITH THE RNC AND DNC.